let's go to this from yahoo it says
russia will be barred from the 2022
men's world cup and other international
sports competitions after fifa and the
international olympic committee levied
extraordinary sanctions in response to
russia's invasion of ukraine
fifa soccer's global governing body
and uefa the sports european governing
body announced monday that they have
banned all russian national teams and
clubs from all competitions until
further notice suspension will likely
remove russia from march's world cup
qualifying playoffs and end its hopes of
earning a birth of the most prestigious
tournament in the international sport
now
if you want to ban russia from the world
cup fine with me where it works for me
sounds good
um in fact you go
even farther than that and how about ban
all countries from the world cup and ban
everybody from soccer and just get rid
of soccer entirely i think that's
probably the best thing that we could
possibly do
but if you're not going to do that you
want to ban russia great i'm all for it
but i can't help but notice
that this is happening only what two
weeks
after the conclusion of the olympics
the olympics which were held in china
china which is a country that is
certainly guilty of not only guilty of
its own rampant human rights abuses
but also there's the little detail about
the fact that china unleashed created it
seems and unleashed a virus on the world
that killed 5 million people
and so after china has unleashed a virus
onto the globe
infected the globe with a virus
that killed 5 million people
it not only
was allowed to attend the olympics but
but it hosted the olympics
and every other country showed up
and we all played games together and had
fun
oh but there was a there was a
diplomatic boycott
so some of the american diplomats they
didn't show up and i'm sure that their
presence was sorely missed
and china they really had their feelings
hurt about that i'm sure
but we still showed up there
so once again you know we're getting
tough with uh russia when it comes to
some of these things anyway
it's still not not all that tough
because we're you know
we're still importing all the oil we're
gonna dump the vodka down the drain but
still import the will
but um
in spite of that when it comes to china
still hosting the olympics we went to
the olympics and there was almost there
was almost no discussion about that's
what blew my mind the entire time
there was some discussion about the
human rights issue
which is good
there was at least discussion about the
fact that china commits all these human
rights abuses
but that to me was like the less
relevant point compared to the fact
that they that they created this virus
in a laboratory and and let it go into
the world and killed five million people
and that detail when it comes to
olympics wasn't even talked about
just uh absolute
hypocrisy and moral inconsistency
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated